but I felt for a while that I was kind
of repeating the same thing yeah yeah
we'll figure out the licensing soon yes
obviously kept pushing
what's a reputation at one point in time
that Spotify was like not gonna work
because of the licensing how close was
it in your estimation percentage-wise to
working at its worst like to not working
at the darkest day what did you think
your chances were the darkest days you
know we had a serious a meeting in New
York it was about a week where it was
pretty evident like everyone just said
no this isn't gonna happen
like don't come back that was
essentially really you know yeah so I
called Martin up and I'm like hey you
know what's going on and for those that
don't know Morgan I will say that he's
he you know the guy just he it doesn't
bother him at all like none of that does
so he's just gonna be okay well that's
totally fine let's go and do something
else
so for him he just listened to what I
said and it's like okay well you know
that sounds stupid but if that's the
case let's go and do something else give
it another couple of weeks and then
we'll figure it out
and and that was incredibly reassuring
for me because you know I I just felt
like we had both invested so much of our
time money had all these employees and
and he was just totally on face but what
happened in those three or four weeks
that made it turn around that's a very
good question that I still wonder
sometimes you know what what ended up
doing is I just canceled my trip back
home to Stockholm you ripped up the
return ticket yeah and ended up camping
out in front of their offices coming
back I had to like tweak my messaging a
little bit and twist things around pay
them a little bit more money figure
things around but it just really turned
and then the other thing that I did
which really saved the company was we
wanted to launch a worldwide day one and
I said okay screw screw it let's not do
the US
let's start in a territory where this
doesn't matter as much to you and let me
prove the model that was brilliant that
took the pressure off yeah and then
everything turned around and that was
great because I had acquired an account
and I had a VPN and I'm a big Bob Dylan
fan and I had no idea that so many
French people loved Bob Dylan enough to
cover every song and only [ __ ] the
French can do Dylan yeah I don't know if
you've ever heard he's and then I bought
the u.s. Spotify yep
and I couldn't get the French Dylan
anywhere can't get it now I had no
comment